[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité il faut sauver la
supérette locale une facture
d'électricité qui s'envole et c'est tout
un village qui se mobilise pour le seul
commerce alimentaire des environs les
explications de wayotv la chaîne de la
Voix du Nord à suivre dans un instant
elle est de retour en abondance la neige
envahie de nouveau les montagnes
françaises en Corse vous allez le voir
les skieurs sont évidemment ravis comme
vous l'entendrez grâce à nos partenaires
sur place de via télépasis ces racines
poussent au bord d'une falaise un arbre
situé en Moselle vient d'être élu plus
belle arbre de France une découverte
remarquable de la rédaction de Moselle
TV et puis en fin d'édition nous
partirons à la rencontre d'une
infirmière passionnée de cosplay cette
activité ou des fans de jeux vidéo se
partent dans le réel des costumes de
leur héros un sujet de vos TV en fin de
journal
une facture d'électricité multipliée par
4 et c'est un village entier qui retient
son souffle à Bernaville dans la Somme
la seule supérette du coin est menacée
de fermeture la cause une facture
d'électricité qui a bondit ces dernières
semaines plusieurs emplois sont menacés
une situation préoccupante pour les
habitants aussi reportage et
explications de Jérémy houblon pour eux
au TV la chaîne de la Voix du Nord et du
Courrier Picard
c'est la seule supérette à plusieurs
kilomètres à la ronde pourtant ce
commerce de Bernaville pourrait bien
fermer ses portes les clients se
distinguaient
indispensable comment ils vont faire les
papilles les mamies qu'on se déplace il
faut avoir 12 voire 15 km on a pu la
poste on a plus le Trésor Public
vraiment les les communistes des Unis
complètement quoi en novembre dernier la
gérante de l'enseigne recevait les
nouveaux tarifs de ses factures
d'électricité applicables en début
d'année 4 fois supérieur au taux
habituel donc vous voyez ça c'est ce que
je payais avant ça c'est ce que je vais
payer en appliquant le nouveau taux de
EDF près de 20 000 euros mensuels
d'électricité un montant injustifié
selon la commerçante qu'on paye plus
cher de 10-15% j'irai comme le cours
actuel de la vie mais pas oui 400 fois
mon prix quoi enfin ça a pas de sens ça
n'a vraiment pas de sens en cas de
fermeture les huit salariés de la
supérette pourraient perdre leur emploi
et une partie de la clientèle bien
souvent âgée pourrait se voir essentiel
inacceptable pour ce collectif faut
savoir qui madame maréchal prend des
commandes par téléphone et qu'elle va
livrer gratuitement tous ces gens là et
qu'elle va même chercher des gens chez
eux pour qu'il fasse leur course elle
les ramène chaque année la supérette
génère plus de 2 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires trop important pour
bénéficier du bouclier tarifaire alors
certains élus locaux en appel
directement aux instances
gouvernementales afin de trouver des
solutions à court terme je dirais c'est
la renégociation d'un contrat qui soit
supportable pour l'entreprise des aides
de l'État bien sûr dans la mesure où
justement nous sommes en zone de
revitalisation rurale et puis après
peut-être des solutions à plus long
terme à revoir comment on peut
structurer cette société pour découpler
des activités et avoir des capacités de
bénéficier du bouclier tarifaire ce
qu'on appelle les trve les tarifs
réglementés de vente de l'électricité la
gérante de l'enseigne se donnait un mois
pour éviter la fermeture sur sa dernière
facture arrivé ce matin le taux annoncé
par son fournisseur d'électricité
n'était pas appliqué
pour l'un des derniers commerces de la
commune
voilà et le reste de l'actualité marquée
aussi par le conflit en Ukraine qui est
entré cette semaine dans son onzième
mois et presque un an après le début de
la guerre la solidarité ne faiblit pas
vous allez le voir la preuve avec
l'Association des pompiers humanitaires
français qui déploie actuellement une
unité mobile de soins à la frontière
entre la Pologne et l'Ukraine cette
infrastructure de 28 mètres carrés était
présenté il y a quelques jours dans la
Loire image et propos recueillies par
Marylise Pariot pour la rédaction de TL7
la télévision de la Loire
est présent depuis le 1er mars en
Ukraine et à la frontière polonaise mais
oui c'est la continuité c'est la suite
c'est la poursuite du projet et c'est on
l'espère quelque part à un moment aussi
l'accompagnement à la restructuration du
système de santé alors reconstruction
modestement mais du pays sans transition
dans ce journal l'intérêt sont nous à
présent à la problématique du gaspillage
alimentaire en France chaque année près
de 10 millions de tonnes de produits
sont jetés à la poubelle pour lutter
contre ce fléau et environnemental de
nombreux acteurs agissent en Gironde de
l'entreprise sain et sauf produit des
conserves à partir de fruits et de
légumes déclassés ou un vendus un
concept anti-gaspi innovant qui se
développe comme a pu le constater dans
les coulisses de l'usine de l'entreprise
les caméras de TV7 la chaîne du groupe
sud-ouest regardez
en dégustant ce petit velouté de
poireaux et pommes de terre Baptiste n'a
pas l'air franchement convaincu je
trouve que c'est un peu trop masqué
sont invités à goûter et noter les
prototypes de produits avant qu'il ne
soit fabriqué des conserves qui ont une
spécificité elles sont toutes faites à
partir de fruits et légumes de
récupération mais c'est pas du tout les
poubelles sont juste des pour la plupart
des des fruits et légumes sont
simplement des fruits déclassés qui
peuvent pas être vendus dans le commerce
parce qu'ils n'ont pas la bonne taille
dans les ateliers on est en pleine
production de citronnades les produits
de sain et sauf sont principalement
commercialisés dans des grandes surfaces
mais aussi dans certaines épiceries
fines face aux géants de
l'agroalimentaire la petite structure de
quinze salariés peinent à se faire une
place d'où sa participation au salon de
référence mondiale de l'hôtellerie
restauration à Lyon nous on essaie de
faire notre place là-dedans avec un
autre concept et vraiment le concept
poussait anti-gaspi et le message
commence à bien passer à bien tourner au
niveau de différentes structures comme
la grande distribution des choses comme
ça mais pas que donc c'est pour ça qu'on
a besoin de cette visibilité là en
France les pertes et gaspillages
alimentaires représentent 10 millions de
tonnes de produits par an soit une
valeur commerciale estimée à 16
milliards d'euros
des chiffres impressionnants qui nous
amènent maintenant à découvrir une autre
initiative pour réduire la pollution de
nos déchets plastiques le fourgon et le
nom d'une entreprise en pleine
croissance son concept est simple
distribué des boissons consignées à
domicile une remise au goût du jour de
la tournée du laitier en quelque sorte
une idée envers qui séduit de plus en
plus de clients un sujet de Linda Bravin
pour la rédaction de Télé Grenoble
voilà une livraison qui aurait été
anodine 40 ans plus tôt alors que la
consigne était encore obligatoire en
France mais depuis les emballages à
usage unique comptant envahi le
quotidien pour changer les nouveaux
usages des consommateurs le fourgon
propose 300 références de boissons
consignées sur son application ou son
site internet une fois que le client a
passé commande il peut être livré dans
les deux heures selon les créneaux de
livraison et normalement ça a été validé
sur l'application et là on peut passer à
la sélection des produits que le client
a demandé donc là on voit c'est une
soupe 5 légumes reste à livrer le client
en camion électrique sans qu'il n'ait à
sortir de son appartement ou porter les
caisses qui pèsent environ 20 kg j'ai
découvert ça hier et je me suis dit que
c'est une bonne idée d'acheter par
exemple les sodas tout ça sous son
passe-temps en acheter en supermarché
tout ça en bouteille en plastique de les
acheter en bouteille en verre parce que
ça coûte pas forcément plus cher et ça
fait beaucoup moins de plastique quoi on
est sensiblement sur les mêmes gammes de
prix que dans certains supermarchés sur
sur certaines gammes de prix en revanche
on sait que sur d'autres gammes on est
moins compétitif des prix moins
attractifs en raison du service rendu et
de la consigne en plus des boissons
soupes café et autres sodas le fourgon
vente aussi quelques produits ménagers
par exemple on est sur une gamme de
détachant textile pareil pour un usage
quotidien à la maison le concept de
vente en contenant consignée n'a pas été
réinstauée par le fourgon mais adapté
aux particuliers quand on va dans un
café ou dans un restaurant très souvent
les bouteilles qui nous servent elles
sont elles-mêmes consignées et nous on
est avec le fourgon on a bénéficié de ce
même réseau là pour l'instant trois
personnes travaillent dans l'entrepôt du
fourgon à Grenoble mais l'entreprise
espère à terme atteindre un effectif de
vin collaborateurs
c'est un service indispensable dont
peuvent bénéficier les personnes âgées
notamment dans les zones rurales le
portage de repas à domicile et d'une
aide précieuse pour les personnes âgées
et isolées à Limoges le service local
livre 150 à 200 repas par jour même le
dimanche et depuis quelques mois la
tournée dominicale s'est transformée en
moment de convivialité comme vous le
voyez sur ces images de cet aliment les
livreurs passent davantage de temps au
domicile des bénéficiaires une nouveauté
appréciée forcément proposé par Benjamin
Delmas
au début il y a un on va dire un peu de
gêne entre nous deux parce que je me dis
est-ce que la discussion va être forcée
ou pas et puis finalement en fait plus
le temps passe plus on reste avec eux en
fait et la discussion elle est pas du
tout forcée et puis ça va naturellement
et puis il y a une confiance aussi qui
s'installe et que l'on vit tout seul il
faut dire le mot
ça fait plaisir d'avoir une personne qui
vient passer un petit moment avec vous
même si c'était pas un temps très long
mais ça fait quand même plaisir de
pouvoir parler un petit peu
elle était plus qu'attendue en montagne
la neige a fait son grand retour sur la
majeure partie des massifs français et
notamment en Corse comme vous le
constatez sur ces très belles images de
la rédaction de via télépasis une neige
abondante qui fait évidemment le bonheur
des skieurs de l'île de Beauté réaction
au micro de Loïc Leprince et de Gaëtan
mobile
on a une belle neige
conditions idéales on a ce qu'il faut
donc bon c'est c'est top
de faire du ski tous ensemble la neige
est bonne ou pas
mal voilà des sourires à l'heure de aux
chaussettes c'est ce qui résonne avec la
joie des kayakistes bretons après
presque un an de travaux il bénéficie
désormais d'un nouveau bassin dernier
cri à Cesson-Sévigné un parcours de plus
de 200 mètres en pleine ville qui
renforce la place de la commune dans la
pratique du canoë-kayak la nouvelle
outil qui doit permettre également de
préparer les Jeux olympiques de 2024 un
sujet de Raphaël tondrillou Gautier pour
la rédaction de thé vert sur place
ce n'est pas souvent que l'on voit un
stade se remplir d'eau pourtant ici à
Cesson-Sévigné ce n'est pas la première
fois ce nouveau bassin d'eau vive vient
doubler l'équipement déjà proposé par la
ville au kayakistes de 120 mètres de
rivière qui peut être programmée à
distance des tailles pratiques un tapis
facilitant l'accès à l'eau à même été
installée un dénivelé qui est plus
important donc un courant qui est plus
fort avec des obstacles que l'on peut
déplacer aménager pour créer des
mouvements d'eau particuliers et donc
c'est une modularité finalement qui est
tout à fait intéressante alors
intéressante pour tous les niveaux c'est
à dire que ça va être utile à la fois
pour nos athlètes de haut niveau mais
aussi pour les pratiquants donc
débutants mais pour l'essayer ce sont
quand même des athlètes de bon niveau
qui se mettent à l'eau ce stade il
l'attendait on va plus être obligé de
bouger comme c'était un peu le cas
surtout depuis que les travaux là c'est
génial on a vraiment des conditions de
standard internationales qui sont bas à
la maison et franchement pour nous c'est
vraiment chouette une pratique qui se
veut ton cœur de ville accessible à tous
pour la commune c'est l'occasion de
briller au niveau national car avec ce
nouvel équipement ce sont les
championnats nationaux et internationaux
qui s'ouvrent aux athlètes locaux
aujourd'hui l'importance c'est de
maintenir les activités des filières
sportives ici dans la ville qui ont été
construits depuis des années et puis
surtout d'avoir un outil qui va nous
permettre de faire vivre le centre-ville
avec des événements un avenir déjà tout
tracé puisque le site de Cesson-Sévigné
a été choisi comme centre d'entraînement
pour les Jeux Olympiques de Paris en
voilà du Kano kayak à l'aviron dans
cette édition regardez c'est très belles
images de nos partenaires de huit
mont-blancs en Savoie le lac du Bourget
accueillera le 25 février prochain une
compétition organisée par le club local
location de voir s'affronter les
meilleures équipages européens et dans
un décor éblouissant mais aussi vous
allez l'entendre de faire découvrir
cette pratique à un nouveau public
explication récoltée par Sébastien
Germain sur place
pour confidentiel parce que c'est
compliqué à mettre en oeuvre c'est à
dire que vous prenez un ballon vous
faites sur 10 mètres carrés vous faites
de dribble et ça va très bien là le le
terrain de foot là c'est le lac donc
c'est pas rien on veut vraiment
expliquer ce qu'est la vie rond et on
veut que toutes les familles disent bah
tiens pourquoi pas montrer ça à nos
enfants parce qu'il va y avoir des
essais si à la fin de l'épreuve qui va
avoir lieu le 25 s'il y a cinq personnes
qui s'inscrivent là moi j'ai gagné mon
pari
voilà le rendez-vous est donc pris le 25
février prochain sur les magnifiques
bords du lac du Bourget en Savoie pour
cette compétition dédiée à l'aviron donc
c'est un événement inédit par son
ampleur et dans l'histoire de la
spéléologie un gouffre dans le
département du Gard c'était écroulé sur
35 mètres de long un phénomène naturel
et impressionnant qui intrigue les
scientifiques pour la sécurité du public
le cité désormais inaccessible les
précisions avec ce sujet pour bien
Occitanie de Chloé bounamo
c'est un événement inédit jamais observé
depuis la naissance de la spéléologie le
gouffre désespéugue à quelques pas de la
commune de Dions dans le Gard s'était
fondé soudainement sur 35 mètres de long
un éboulement conséquent de 5000 mètres
cubes l'eau a circulé à la base de ce
limon accumulé parce que le limon c'est
perméable et a fini par creuser sous le
limon et le sol de la salle qui était
formé de ce limon un jour a été
tellement creusé que la route
steffondrée pour tous les scientifiques
c'est un trésor c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que il m'a suffit de quelques coups de
téléphone pour assembler une équipe de
scientifiques de niveau national qui
n'ont pas hésité une seconde avant de
venir le risque de chutes pourrait bien
être mortel dans une eau à 3 degrés face
à l'ampleur du phénomène le maire a pris
un arrêté municipal interdisant l'accès
au site ne venez pas
ne descendez pas dans le gouffre c'est
pas stabilisé pour l'instant le
phénomène d'éboulement est encore à
craindre en cas d'accident un dispositif
d'urgence a été mis en place afin d'agir
plus rapidement ce gouffre d'une valeur
symbolique pour les habitants accueille
habituellement randonneurs et familles
aujourd'hui seuls les scientifiques ont
accès aussi l'étude reste à confirmer
mais la trace d'une activité néolithique
pourrait bien être l'un des premiers
secrets que le gouffre pourrait nous
révéler
et des secrets justement lui il espère
en dévoiler quelques-uns le satellite
driss est paré pour son décollage dans
quelques semaines depuis la Guyane
objectif Jupiter et c'est l'une glacée
pour ce mastodonte de plus de 6 tonnes
que vous découvrez à l'écran
actuellement un voyage de 7 ans et demi
et de 600 millions de kilomètres rien
que ça pour savoir si les lunes de
Jupiter réunissent les conditions
propices à la vie précision au micro de
Clément Gacy notre partenaire de la
Dépêche du Midi
là on a le satellite qui est
complètement assemblé dans sa
configuration quasiment prête pour le
lancement et on est en train de terminer
les essais fonctionnels c'est-à-dire on
teste le logiciel du satellite on part
vers le système je viens pour comprendre
comment des lunes de glace peuvent
abriter des conditions favorables à la
vie telle que nous la connaissons nous
savons que certaines cellules de glace
abritent en profondeur des océans d'eau
liquides dans lesquels des conditions
les conditions thermiques et chimiques
pourrait permettre à la vie telle qu'on
la connaît d'apparaître et de se
développer
voilà et le décollage du satellite Driss
et programmé pour le 5 avril prochain
tout à fait autre chose majestueux et
suspendue à 6 mètres de hauteur le plus
bel arbre de France se trouve en Moselle
désigné ainsi par le jury du concours
organisé par l'Office National des
Forêts et le magazine terre sauvage
c'est un être situé dans une petite
commune qui vient de recevoir cette
distinction principale argument cet
arbre remarquable et suspendu au bord
d'une paroi une drôle de façon de
croître me dire et vous découverte de
collines l'expert pour Moselle TV
regardez
[Musique]
la question ne se pose plus pour le jury
le plus bel arbre de France est bien
dans les forêts mosellanes un être de 25
mètres de haut niché dans le canyon de
Saint-Hubert
c'est sa position puisqu'il est accroché
au rocher grâce à son système racinaire
que du développé pour pour se maintenir
justement j'ai rarement vu un arbre qui
a système racinaire comme celui-là quoi
et puis il est d'accord sur le chemin
est très beau et pour venir admirer cet
arbre centenaire mieux vaut enfiler une
bonne paire de baskets suspendue à 6
mètres de hauteur son implantation lui a
permis de se démarquer parmi les 14
autres régions de France c'est un peu un
modèle un modèle une leçon de vie même
en partant dans dans des conditions très
mauvaises et bah si on se bat on peut
réussir et lui il a réussi il s'est
ancré solidement il est reconnu c'est au
détour d'une balade en forêt que
Delphine et les autres membres de
l'association être vivant ont inscrit
l'arbre au concours organisé par le
magazines terres sauvage la Moselle
n'est pas très connue en tout cas à
l'extérieur pour son patrimoine naturel
les atouts qu'on va lui prêter d'office
ça va être territoire frontalier ça va
être son histoire le but c'était de
montrer qu'elle a un patrimoine naturel
intéressant exceptionnel grâce au prix
du jury ce village de 200 âmes voient
désormais défiler les amoureux de la
nature c'est pas la foule qui vient d'un
coup c'est des passages réguliers tout
au long de la journée surtout les
week-ends des familles qui viennent avec
les enfants la plupart des gens qu'on
qu'on a pu croiser était enchanté de
leur découverte quoi objectif à présent
obtenir des financements pour développer
les chemins de randonnée de Saint-Hubert
détenteurs du plus bel arbre de France
voilà 17 ans il vient de remporter le
titre de meilleur apprenti de France
Thomas Collignon c'est son nom est un
jeune homme spécialisé en métallurgie
serrurerie une passion rare pour son âge
qu'il perfectionne au sein d'une
entreprise locale rencontre et portrait
signé de la rédaction de Canal 32 dans
l'Aube
enfant Thomas Collignon a semblé déjà
des pièces métalliques cet étudiant en
bac pro à l'ium de Rosières a voulu
dépasser ses limites en se portant
candidat au concours du meilleur
apprenti dans son domaine le sujet
c'était une rampe d'escalier avec comme
motif un coq et les canaux qui étaient
imposés que les vis tête fraisée doivent
être soignées pour pas gêner que quand
on passe la main et ça soit
professionnel qui est rien qui raccroche
160 heures de travail ont été
nécessaires pour répondre à un tel
niveau d'exigence soit chez lui les
week-ends
une PME de 25 salariés intervenant
parfois pour la restauration de
monuments prestigieux ici le gérant a
tout intérêt à consacrer du temps pour
la transmission des savoir-faire auprès
d'apprenti ou de compagnons on attire
des salariés qui sont intéressés par les
ouvrages qu'on réalise en fin de compte
on a beaucoup beaucoup de d'entreprises
qui savent faire de l'aluminium des
assemblages des fenêtres mais des
métalliers pures pour défaire de la
rampe d'escalier ce qui est Louis XV oui
c'est pour faire des rampes débillardées
et des métalliers on en a de moins en
moins
Thomas Collignon va chercher sa médaille
le mois prochain il se donne 10 ans pour
tenter le concours de Meilleur Ouvrier
de France
voilà un savoir-faire précieux qui nous
conduit dans la Sarthe à présent à la
découverte du travail d'une
restauratrice de livres anciens à 28 ans
Marina villa va ouvert il y a deux ans
son atelier près du Mans un pari osé
alors que le métier tente à se raréfier
ils ne sont plus que 6 à proposer un tel
service dans son département reportage
d'Enzo Maubert pour la rédaction de LM
TV Sarthe
quand je dois expliquer aux enfants en
fait je dis tout simplement que je suis
un médecin des livres
puisque mon rôle en fait c'est de les
soigner peu importe la malédique et
qu'ils ont pu avoir
c'est un métier qui demande à la fois
patience et minutie
dans son atelier Marina restaure de
petites trésors des livres anciens
parfois vieux de plusieurs siècles qui
entre ses mains revivent je suis en
train de retirer l'ancienne carte ado
donc la carte de dos en fait c'est une
sorte de papier un petit peu épais et
surtout très très dense qui va permettre
en fait de rigidifier le dos du livre
donc là en fait j'utilise une colle très
très diluée avec de l'eau qui va
permettre de ramollir tout simplement le
carton pour pouvoir en fait le décoller
sans abîmer le cuir caoutchou la
restauration est un art exigeant chaque
retouche est pensé et réfléchie Marina
doit rester la petite main invisible
celle qui répare sans toucher à l'âme du
livre on n'est pas là pour créer un
objet artistique on est là pour pour
vraiment en fait respecter la matière
ancienne et le travail qui a été fait
avant nous tous les livres n'ont donc
pas vocation à être restauré c'est le
cas de ce manuscrit dont la couverture a
totalement brûlé on peut pas faire de
restauration en proprement parler
puisque
99% en fait des éléments au sein de la
couverture sont disparus les histoires
le vécu se mêlent souvent au travail de
la restauratrice des souvenirs familiaux
ou parfois même de petits objets cachés
entre les pages ça m'est déjà arrivé de
trouver sur un livre qui était grand
comme ça en fait des restes d'un
bracelet en paix en fait il y avait
vraiment des perles mais minuscules en
verre avec des petits bouts du fil de
soie qu'il tenaient des petits bouts
d'histoire toujours bien gardés pour
Marina restaurer un livre c'est aussi
faire parler notre passé
connaissez-vous le cosplay venu des
États-Unis cette activité consiste à se
mettre dans la peau de son personnage de
fiction préféré Christelle alias Lille
ou Christ est devenu championne d'Europe
de cosplay en novembre dernier cette
infirmière confectionnelle même c'est
costumes et ses accessoires et vous
allez voir avec ce reportage de Vosges
télévision il s'agit d'un travail très
minutieux Thierry Lasson et Hélène
Leplat ont rencontré Christelle ou
plutôt l'île ou Christ à son domicile
regardez
c'est un mot d'appart celui des
passionnés de jeux vidéo et
d'incarnation de personnages de fiction
le cosplay est né aux États-Unis en 1939
Christelle et cosplayeuse cette
vosgienne a découvert le concept il y a
8 ans et depuis la passion a pris le
dessus plus connu sous le nom de l'île
ou Christ c'est les mêmes devenus
championne d'Europe de cette discipline
lors d'une convention de cosplay à
Toulouse en novembre dernier c'est chez
elle à cercueil où elle confectionne
elle-même ses tenues et accessoires que
nous l'avons retrouvé j'ai utilisé du
pain d'épauges avec du cuir pour le
contour tout de suite c'est pour moi
c'est sûr c'est voilà de la scène des
costumes
de la recherche pour faire des costumes
enfin voilà tout y était donc je me suis
dit il faut que j'en fasse
de nature plutôt timide sa personnalité
une fois le costume revêtu change du
tout au tout Christelle vittéralement
les différents rôles qu'elle veut
interpréter mais c'est le costume qui au
final fait la différence dans le choix
de son interprétation maintenant que
j'ai trouvé ma matière qui est vraiment
le cuir le cuir voilà j'adore le
travailler donc je cherche un costume en
cuir et après vraiment que le personnage
soit intéressant qui soit profond
généralement des femmes qui sont assez
fortes qui ont un caractère
en novembre lors de sa victoire à la
convention du Toulouse Game Show elle
incarnait le personnage de la princesse
cyrila de Sintra une sorceleuse issue du
jeu vidéo The Witcher
après avoir enchaîné les concours Lilou
chris a rengainé son épée enfin pas
totalement puisqu'elle se consacre
désormais à la conception et à la vente
de costumes et d'accessoires elle sera
l'invité d'honneur les 25 et 26 février
prochain à Épinal de spinatori la
convention geek dédiée à la pop culture
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci d'avoir suivi le grand JT des
territoires on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle édition au revoir à
tous
[Musique]